ruby est là est-ce qu'elle peut venir
rubis sur l'ongle
biais là parce que la libye va nous dire
un truc voilà venez là on va faire
entrer rugby et à prêcher l'époque c'est
pas des bonnes après j'ai pas des bonnes
nouvelles j'ai pas des bonnes nouvelles
rues bizien la vache et applaudissements
pour une
ça me tue va bien ça va salut merci
d'être passé quoi bon ça me fait plaisir
via la loi à côté moi ton merde pas
comment ça va déjà
c'est comment la production va payer la
fibre on est en edge bactéries je te
cache pas qu'on était très contente pour
se voir c'est quoi ces problèmes
techniques comme par hasard quand je
gagne à des problèmes débat pose t'on
les bonnes questions
tamesloht de tomber sur toi lui ce sens
très bon tu sais que déjà ses barbies je
me lavais
et ne bannirait
classique et expliqué
que ces créneaux très fan de toi le
jeune homme l'a 6 à 6 et pourtant de la
boire il m'avait critique les non non
mais il est content de voir
ben on va discuter
[Musique]
c'est quoi ces mots là
c'est quoi
[Musique]
kelly est très fan de toi mais je laime
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle d'ailleurs
alors d'ensacher bernard montiel
[Rires]